tout à l'heure alors il me reste une
saison sur ses vitres excès c'est l'info
voilà qui est sorti ce week-end c'est
franck appelé tôt le patron de ses huit
cas dit il n'ya aucune inquiétude cyril
hanouna sera bien encore sur ces 8 à la
rentrée prochaine un nouveau contrat
pluriannuel est en cours de négociation
sans inflation alors on va pas se mentir
je rappelle ce que signifie son
inflation
ça signifie pas d'augmentation je vous
rassure je n'en demande pas on est déjà
assez heureux comme ça franchement et
cdi voilà donc et on est assez heureux
sur ces 8 est ce que je vous dis
franchement voilà on est en
renégociation avec ses 8 peut-être pour
continuer avec moi sur ces 8 vous le
savez de façon quoi qu'il arrive et je
vous le dis l'année prochaine même si
voilà je ne suis plus là sachez que les
chroniqueurs seront encore là puisque je
serai producteur quand même sur ces vite
que vous vous serez là peut-être sans
moi avec peut-être un nouvel animateur
non non ça va bien mais je vous dit mon
nom mais pas et peut-être
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
en pensez vous sent us que penser on
doit rester sur ces huit castel bas je
pense que c'est vous qui avez la réponse
maintenant honnêtement vous êtes moi
j'adore ces voix là vous êtes images de
la chaîne je pense que vous devez rester
sur ces huit en plus qu'il reste le
dimanche où il n'y a pas d'émission avec
vous non
petitement aura sera le samedi soir
après tant de lundi donc ça ça me plaît
plus avec vos lundi évidemment je pense
honnêtement je pense que vous êtes
heureux sur ces 8 je pense que c'est
vite c'est une chaîne qui est fait pour
vous je vois pas une autre chaîne vous
pourriez faire autant de choses et être
aussi libre alors peut-être pas des
grandes chaînes mais j'aimerais y avait
une autre idée pour eux mais je vais la
garder pour moi je pense que si un
transfert à faire cesser c'est pas vers
m6 s'est pas vers tf1
c'est à une plus petite chaîne ou vos
compétences et votre arrivée va quitter
bella le grand patron de groupe
effectivement j'ai géré de prendre cyril
pour passer pour la chaîne passe de
trois et demi ou 4 pas ça pour le coup
on sait que si vous allez sur une chaîne
comme ça vous allez refaire un million
millions 2 et pour une chaîne à 18h 21h
c'est un c'est une énorme donc moi si
j'étais à la concurrence je rêve où
chercher mais sur une plus petite chaîne
dont jean michel hayat a déjà vu un
joueur de l adolescence adn ans lille 2
annonce le plus plu aux veaux syrie quel
intérêt pour lui il s'en fout de la
chaîne des progrès mais il veut c'est
lui qui m'a largué il y eu des coups à
prendre à aller ailleurs peu dans une
souris rose couchée partir moi je trouve
qu'il faut pas chercher la pas chasser
la proie pour l'ombre
vous êtes très bien ici c'est la chaîne
qui nous a permis d'exploser aux
quotidiennes voilà il nous permet de
faire des choses incroyables qu'on
ferait jamahirya autrichienne ou prendre
un secteur où est très nature du patron
et c'est de faire des farandoles dans la
rue de faire des folies
voilà ça serait trop formaté ailleurs
ici on se plaît pourquoi lier après
roger rabbit
alors incontestablement comme l'a dit
jean michel vous êtes le roi vous êtes
le boss vous êtes le taulier de ses
limites
d'ailleurs ses limites cyril hanouna ou
cyril hanouna ses limites pour moi c'est
la même chose
je pense que d'ailleurs semita plus
besoin de vous que vous vous n'avez
besoin de ses limites
après moi je parle sportif voilà à
l'homme qui aime les défis
si vous étiez nadal nadal il a gagné
tous les roland garros mais lui veut
quand même gagné wimbledon il a gagné ou
vous avez voilà vous vous avez gagné
finalement le pari c'est limite mais ce
que vous n'avez pas envie d'aller gagner
ailleurs voilà et moi je me dis que
après la crise de la quarantaine
enfin vous avez peut-être pas loin de 40
ans peut-être un petit peu plus ou un
petit peu moins je sais pas mystère
vous retournez que vous avez envie
d'être finalement l'homme surprenant
gilles mais il n'y a pas une autre
chaîne ou quand vous aurez une idée le
jeudi elle sera à l'antenne le vendredi
et si c'est ça vous appelez le patron
j'ai une idée deux jours avant après
c'est à l'antenne après le sac pas trop
le fut directeur
[Rires]
la chaîne elle va avec vous moi j'ai
peur que dans un groupe comme m6 comme
un peu plus contraintes financières vont
s'ennuyer
six heures après et ça me gêne un peu le
sens inflation parce que quand nos
gardes et neymar on lui dit pas je
t'augmente pas et donc j'ai beaucoup
aimé le petit sans effacement je vous le
dis moi et mes qui disent bien entendu
aux marrons alors franchement moi je
pense en ce moment vraiment et ben moi
je demanderais fermé d'augmentation oui
franchement c'est pousser pas c'est pas
le moment oui mais vous la donne
oui mais bon endroit n'ont pas
franchement donc vraiment je vous ai
écouté parler et vous aviez tout à
l'heure si je m'en vais il y aura un
vrai producteur il y aura notamment
matters si c'est pour faire ça non il
faut arrêter pmp carrément et faire
autre chose et moi je vous verrai bien
vous appliquez sur balances ton post qui
est déjà le cas faire un vrai bal en ce
temps de pause bien bien musclés comme
c'est déjà le cas et faire de la variété
faire des grands prime extraordinary ou
mais ici sur ces mythes mais non c'est
une obsession rester s'il s'en va il
s'en va oui je m'en vais péter le
vaisseau amiral
oui on va pas forcément mauvais jugement
v6 joreige bref ils s'en prennent à
questembert ce que touche actu suis
beaucoup ce qu'ils payent mais moi moi
je vous suis depuis depuis toujours
jamais vraiment je pense qu'il faut
rester parce qu'on peut sont à une
émission de prévente à une olympiade à
faire
j'appelle voiture merci le temps pas
l'avenir vous avez vous êtes là c'est
celle où comme comme c'est lui booba ya
le ciridd c'est comme les albums de
martine de cyril de mardi du mercredi et
jeudi de vendredi et du samedi bientôt
du dimanche non ouais tu vous dit que
voilà il faut toujours discuter avec les
gens qui veulent discuter avec vous je
sais que ya des groupes qui discute
toujours avec vous c'est toujours
intéressant de les voir parce que comme
vous avez une forte personnalité nous
imposera ailleurs ce que vous avez
ressenti à léopard donc ne soyons pas
quand même voilà ici c'était rien
d'abouti partir mérite on m'a mis la
question est bien sûr en doute
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
faut pas l'embêter y sont attendus je
veux la prochaine la madame valérie
benaïm non moi vous connaissant un petit
peu les connaissant votre caractère qui
est que un garçon qui ont peint qui est
du cas du mal à ce qu'on lui impose des
choses ici c'est une maison vous
connaissez c'est une maison avec
laquelle vous avez des relations presque
filial c'est à dire vraiment voilà de
familiaux si vous avez une idée le
mercredi pouvez la mettre en place le
samedi et des besoins de réactivité que
ça puisse bouger dans les grosses autre
maison c'est assez figée faut passer par
15 interlocuteurs et on décide d'un truc
ou pas au bout de six mois je pense que
c'est pas réellement fait pour vous donc
moi je vous vois vraiment heureux ici je
vois pas pourquoi aller chercher
ailleurs quelque chose que vous avez
déjà ici parce qu'il aime bien les deux
challenges et il n'aime pas le confort
quand ça dure trop longtemps il est
séparé du jour du temps sur lui l'idée
de mariama d'aller à leur faire perdre
un coût énorme sur une autre sur une
petite chaîne qui s'est passé
vous ferez des émissions slip un je vous
le dis je le fais tout lu sur ap kelly
moi je pense que vous avez des habitudes
sur cette chaîne vous êtes beaucoup
libre et mais je pense que vous avez les
capacités de prendre votre liberté aussi
ailleurs comme sur m6 oui et on peut
imposer votre style
toi tu bouffe à tous les râteliers
j'irai aussi mais au fait vous vous
aviez je pense que vous êtes comme un
couple ex est vite ça fait huit ans que
vous êtes ensemble vous pouvez passer à
autre chose mais il faut que vous
restiez accès vite parce que vous ne
vous aurais jamais la liberté que vous
avez sur ces 8 sur une autre chaîne
fallait peut-être froid non parce que la
grosse rigolade vous avez eu l'idée
le lundi vous l'avez fait devant jordi
il ya aucune chaîne qui fonctionne comme
ça aujourd'hui en france il faut vous
restiez sur ces 8 vous avez besoin de
s'éviter ces 8 a besoin de vous albrand
parce que tu t'en fous landreau - chez
moi mais c'est que la c8 pour moi c'est
toi qui l'a fait en vrai était bien là
ça ton image se renouveler sur la chaîne
louis ouais mais moi je te trouve bien
vu la croissance
c'est lisa chez isa qui va pas être
contente mâché rien j'aime beaucoup ça
va très bien ça moi c est ce que vous
avez déjà quelque chose dans votre tête
de penser que je vous savez bien entendu
à chaque fois des avancées mais c'est
vrai qu'on a mis en place beaucoup
beaucoup de nouvelles marques sur ces
vies qui marche bien comme balances ton
poste à la grosse rigolade 4 hélène est
marié à la grande marque amp donc c'est
vrai qu'on a mis beaucoup de marques
voilà en place après on va voir est-ce
qu'on va partir avec si on part avec les
marques ou bien est-ce qu'on va rester
sur ces vitaux je vous tiendrai au
courant mais c'est bien parti
pourquoi ça se passe bien avec les
décisions que vous prenez celle où
est-ce que vous en parlez à votre papa
maman alors je l'apprends seul toujours
sa seule face à un destin passe un crime
face à cris non mais je vous dire en
tout cas je vous le dis si ces huit veut
que je reste
voilà et si le grand patron du groupe
canal veut que je reste bien entendu je
resterai puisque il est hors de question
que je leur fasse un coup dans le dos et
eux nous ont donné notre chaîne option
sur ces 8 pers hier
bien sûr s'ils veulent que je reste je
resterai quoi qu'il arrive voilà donc
c'est eux qui ont les clés jamais je les
trahirait s'ils veulent que je reste je
resterai avec eux bien sûr voilà s'ils
veulent même s'il
[Applaudissements]